[Music]
what's up dickies the curse thickest
that comes what is happening it is 10
a.m
on a
beautiful monday morning
after a fresh ass calabasas fight
companion we had a great time man it was
uh
ah you know i don't i don't [ __ ] on the
ufc ufc 270 but i'd say it's more
entertaining than the fight card let's
be honest um
yeah that was always fun to do hopefully
you guys tuned in
if you didn't you can watch it right now
on thick boy youtube or any uh platform
where you listen to podcasts spotify
itunes i don't know any others but you
know what i'm saying you can watch it on
those if you want uh go check it out man
it was a great time uh far right chris
makes appearance and it was absolutely
hilarious um
before we get into a few housekeeping
notes i am in atlanta
um we just booked atlanta the punchline
in atlanta is february 3rd through the
5th that's coming up man that is coming
up that is february 3rd through the 5th
this uh wednesday there are 15 tickets
left for shaub and friends hollywood uh
improv los angeles california january
26th that's this freaking wednesday kids
this wednesday will be shaban friends uh
some very special guests hell of a
lineup uh then that is wednesday one
show only at 8 pm in los angeles
california hollywood improv after that
should be
next week is february 3rd through the
5th atlanta georgia have been in georgia
or atlanta in about four years on tour
and then uh also kind of fairly newly
announced sacramento california again
punchline sacramento california's
february 24th through the 26th so get
your tickets at thickboy.com or
fatkz.com
uh there are other housekeeping notes if
you want to listen anything i do food
truck
calabash fight companions
classic companions
fighting kid
the shop show
bonus content uh go to super cast man
you go to thick thick boy.supercast.com
now
and you get everything i do plus bonus
shows bonus content ad freaking free
ad free man and uh for all the new super
cast subscribers to watch our videos ad
free just click on the link in the
details box of the audio from there
you'll be able to access the video
straight uh through your super cast
dashboard super easy all right but that
is uh thickboy.supercast.com
for ad-free and bonus shows bonus
content uh get you some man get you some
but uh let's just jump right into it
because we're coming off a juicy
juicy
drama filled big ass pay-per-view that
featured francis ingano sierra gone
you know
i uh
this isn't one of those things where i
come in monday morning told you so told
you france is going to beat them because
i i don't think anybody thought
francis was going to out grapple him
grapple him and uh use his wrestling
um
you know in the fourth and especially in
the fifth round to win this fight
i sure as hell didn't think that i
thought he was going to win and i told
you guys why you should be rooting for
francis to win and what he represents
i think
that to even double down on that
dana not giving francis the belt and not
attending the press conference
afterwards shows you even more why you
should be rooting for francis this isn't
a
you know me versus dana thing or
anti-ufc no one's more ufc i if you cut
my wrist ufc leaks out of it i ride and
die with the ufc this isn't that this is
just you know it's a rare occasion when
a guy in francis ngano who's the face
the heavyweight division one the best
knockout artist of all time if not the
best
for really the first time decide to bank
on himself and say no i'm not going to
resign i'm a test free agency because i
want that tyson fury fight to make [ __ ]
you money and i'm a bank on myself and i
promise you know
nobody in that ufc uh staffing today was
banking on francis when that fight and
was hoping they'd win that fight um
because i don't want to announce it on
here but i'm
pretty close with the francis camp and i
you know
he completely tore his mcl complete tear
of his mcl
so when he has the knee braces on and
you're seeing like man why isn't francis
throwing more punches i'm sure a lot of
you were asking why isn't he doing this
why do you do this
i'm not going to out the guy and it gets
back to his opponent in the ufc that he
you know blew his freaking mcl out but
try throwing a punch uh when when your
knees all messed up you're talking a
complete tear of the mcl his acl is in
danger as well um
so going to that fight imagine being
francis and ghana and his team and
granted his team uh again
very close to source told me that they
didn't want him to fight they wanted him
to postpone the fight but
you know
the way these knee surgeries work these
days if he's going to have a complete
reconstructive knee because you're
talking about mcl
acl damage you know pcl
it's messed up in their man messed up
the point where he can't throw a punch
which is why he didn't land any punches
on saturday night but still won the
fight you should be impressed but
if he does have to have reconstructive
knee surgery not just
you know a fix a slight fix of mcl or
you know a cadaver
ligament in the
mcl a complete reconstruction of the
knee he's out an entire year
so
he just didn't feel like he could do
that and uh skip this fight and be our
entire year and then i think the tyson
fury all the hype goes away if you're
out of sight out of mind so he wasn't
gonna do that so this monster this
badass with all the pressure of not
resigning the ufc of fighting a complete
monster in serial gun who knows what
you're good at to have the chip stacked
completely against you this dude with a
blown out mcl
fought the second scariest guy in the
heavyweight division and beat him
and beat him nothing was wrong with
cyril gone he got the best version of
cyril cyril just did it you know i
thought his movement was good early on
but cyril he knows the power and i don't
think cyril was aware that francis
uh was so goddamn strong with these
takedowns now on the ground is it gonna
blow your hair back watching these two
grapple nope
um
if you had a preconceived notion that
the somebody was going to get knocked
out early on or this can be a slugfest
you probably were disappointed in the
main event
but
again and i offered to you know put my
friends penises in my mouth if this went
to a decision and i really regret that
but um
[Music]
i think you know if you had those
preconceived notions that you're looking
for a knockout or slugfest which you
should if you didn't know going into it
what exactly was going on with francis
you might have been disappointed but i
think for me knowing uh about his mcl
you know i it's think about that man
your entire livelihood your entire
career is banking on beating sirogon
this
monster who we've never really seen a
heavyweight move like him
he knows you your entire career your
everything you resign with the ufc tyson
fury
basically the rest of your life is going
to be predicated on not only being
serial gun which is tough to do on two
good knees but one of them's can be
compromised and always a compromise your
mcl is blown out if you've ever had a
knee injury dude to throw a punch
especially at the power and the torque
and the force that francis throws his
punches at you need your knee he doesn't
have a knee man and he was still
this is what should be impressive forget
about the knockouts within the slugfest
francis went into that fight some
mentally strongly as [ __ ] guys went
into that fight on one leg and beat a
healthy 100
serial gun on one leg with all that
pressure so the criticism of the fight
is born what take all that out think
about going into the biggest day of your
life and you have one leg to do it
and you beat cyril gone
the guy who has the best footwork
fundamentally probably the best hands
kicks everything in the ufc and you did
it on one freaking leg and you don't
respect that get the [ __ ] out of here
that's insane
the mental capacity get it done to
believe in yourself for your team to
believe in yourself even when your
team's saying uh i think we should
postpone this he goes nope there's too
much writing i gotta figure out way to
get it done
it's not like he's some grappling wizard
or jiu jitsu or wrestling you know
expert not far from it you saw it on the
ground his position was decent you know
positioning he's heavy on top uh cyril
gone going for the leg locks
you know for those jiu jitsu uh
heads out there you would look at like i
did you know sierra gone on the ground
you know his framing his hands wasn't
great you know you're watching
blue purple belt [ __ ] not at a high
level and we don't want to see that but
again take all that criticism out of it
because you want to knock out take all
that out of it francis with all that
pressure
still found a way to get it done nor did
he did it did he get it done he got it
done in something that he's not good at
he's not a good grappler never been
known for his cardio
ever
he's a knockout artist he gets
the most spent in the [ __ ] knockdown
the past four years like two minutes
he went 25 minutes of grappling figured
out how not to get hit barely ever got
hit didn't land anything but got him
down and got the [ __ ] win man
and here's a little side note for you so
i'm sure a lot of you
were like oh i bet tyson fury's watching
this and he doesn't want any part of it
and
from my sources which are very close to
this situation
tyson fury contact them and he couldn't
be more into it this made him more
excited to fight francis
congratulations francis but if you want
to make some real money come see the
gypsy king
yes and his team has been in
communication with francis's team
and
let me tell you something if you thought
by fury satan that you know francis is
grappling and he didn't look great
and you thought oh man that fury fights
out of here
it freaking put a rocket pack on this
[ __ ] thing and now we're even closer
to getting that fight and again if
you're a fight fan if you want to be
anti-ufc anti-dana white but if you're a
fight fan you want francis to get that
tyson fury fight you want him to change
the game you want him to learn and see
what jake paul is doing to get 40
million in a single year and you want a
guy of francis who's worked his entire
life for this to be able to go and do
something like that that's exactly what
we want that's exactly what we're
getting and you have to celebrate that
whether you're in with your whether you
grew up with cyril gone in [ __ ]
middle school or not i don't give a [ __ ]
for the game you need francis to carry
on with the path that he has taken and
his agent markel is getting a ton of
[ __ ] people you're the reason that's
here
he's the only guy with the hindsight and
the vision and the balls to risk all
this
and get all this backlash from the mma
media and dana white and the ufc brass
and all that stuff and still double down
and believe so much in his client
francis that they're still continuing to
do this
with a blown out mcl
when you entrepreneurs out there you
know how risky it is when you bet on
yourself think about betting on a guy in
the fight business with a blown out
[ __ ] knee against cyril gone
what
how does that not get you
on board the francis ingano train
it should it's amazing man and then
ah cheers
and then
it's too early for that but whatever i'm
hyped up about francis and then think
about this
so you bank on yourself right you beat a
healthy serial gun you probably should
have won that fight
in the odds uh maker's eyes especially
you know what the odds would have been
if it was released he went in that fight
with the mcl
he's a plus 600 plus 500 it's insane so
imagine the odds he's beating but then
you accomplish that right
and then the guy who pays your bills
doesn't even have the dignity to come
into the octagon and give you your world
championship belt
not only did he not do that which we
haven't seen in a very long time not
only did he not do that he doesn't
attend the press conference
i i have no ill will towards dana i just
think when it comes to this stuff
whether dave whether francis leaves
whether izzy were to leave or conor were
to leave or name anybody you want you
know if if they're to leave
you're still you still won dana if if
i'm his writer if i'm his right hand man
i'm his assistant
and we're sitting uh caged side next to
each other and you know francis won and
if dana would be like [ __ ] it i'm not
going out there man i'm not doing this
but i go hey can i talk to you real
quick come here dude you're worth you're
worth 400 million you've won you won
yeah and by you doing this it's not
helping anybody it's kind of a [ __ ]
move so could you just get in there
you've still won dude you've won so
after this remember we're still going to
jump on your private jet and head to
whatever [ __ ]
state you want because you have a house
all over we're we've we still want i
wouldn't do this a bad look i don't know
how
anybody in his camp doesn't tell him
don't be a sore loser man don't be also
you didn't lose really you didn't lose
this is a guy that
if he could make that money that he's
going for against tyson fury in the ufc
he wouldn't go anywhere the reason he is
because
maybe you think and you know money
didn't it maybe you think you're paying
well but you're not we've seen the pay
the payouts there what do you make 600
grand that's your your heavyweight
chance making 600 grand
and he's fighting once every [ __ ]
three years or whatever it is once a
year it's tough man
it's tough so i just wish
dana handled it a little different
and i thought maybe
and it's one of the reasons we love and
hate dana because he does act like this
but i think
when it comes to francis
he's on
he's not doing anything that
you wouldn't have done when you were
coming up man you know you're talking
about a guy who's banking himself you
banked on yourself
and that's why the ufc is where it's at
and everyone celebrates you for that
you've won man you did great there's no
reason to [ __ ] on a guy or you know have
a negative opinion on the guy because he
wants to negotiate or banking himself
for more money down the road i i for the
life of me i can't understand it
i just can't it's not a it's not a
winner's mentality i know dana has more
money than me and more successful me i
just don't think that is a winner's
mentality i don't think successful
people should think like that and now
maybe he has so much money in the bank
he doesn't give a [ __ ] and but it's not
like if france to leave or whatever he's
gonna do hurts your business model your
business model is predicated on
fulfilling fights for espn you're good
you're still gonna have a
record-breaking year whether france is
there or not
why not be i've never understood i've
never understood it from the matchmakers
and joe silva to dana white uh i know
maynard's a good guy
just all of them i i just
i never understand it why it can't be
cool to these guys
and because you guys know more so than
anybody what these guys are risking and
their careers and their health is on the
line and they have families and it's
just
i never understood how you don't you
should worship these guys man you should
be bowing down to these guys you should
be open to francis uh in the
negotiations if he goes hey i wanna
fight fury how much bigger would it be
if you guys were involved because
nobody's better at marketing promotion
than dana white in the ufc
how much more mike could we all make if
you guys were cool and you paid me
somewhat of a great salary that i'm
asking for to fight in mixed martial
arts but then also you let me bounce
over and fight tyson fury and co-promote
it
you've done it before
why not why not do with francis why be
mean to francis i don't get it
i don't get it francis isn't difficult
um i think you know his team and markel
and ca you know i think they they are
you know pushing back a little bit
that's why he hires those guys francis
didn't hire those guys he didn't hire
wme who in wme endeavor who owns the ufc
because if he did that
it'd be a conflict of interest right so
if your heavyweight champ wants to
bounce and go somewhere else but you're
represented by the same company that
owns the organization you fight in
the conflict of interest right
because
if they own the ufc
they're not going to want you to bounce
over here and bring down the stock of
the
organization that they paid all this
money to right so it's a conflict of
interest so why any ufc fighters
with wme who owns the ufc
it makes no sense there couldn't be a
bigger conflict of interest
like no nfl player is
with the same agent that owns
all of it or no nfl players were the
same agent of their head coach or roger
goodell
it makes no sense they're going to move
in a different way that benefits their
bottom dollar
so i think for
francis one of the reasons he gets all
the [ __ ] and again it's not all francis
his team's saying hey man you want this
[ __ ] you money these are the moves we're
gonna have to make it's gonna get dicey
trust in the process believe
staff social media just win baby that's
what they're doing
if you can't ride with that you ain't
[ __ ]
but i just
i don't get i don't get if you're dating
while you don't go to the press
conference so i don't put the belt
around i'm like why make more of this a
story
because by you doing that
to me
shows that francis is winning
because if it didn't hurt you wouldn't
be doing this stuff
never heard of that
i don't get it we'll never understand it
but if you're a francis fan man uh you
should be happy that on one leg he beat
a monster and cheryl gunn i know not the
knockout we wanted not the highlight
that we wanted it didn't break espn
sports center top ten
i get all that but just from the
standpoint of you knowing what he was
facing going to this and i told you this
fight is so much bigger than just
francis being the heavyweight champion
of the world in the ufc this is so much
bigger what he's doing is going to set
the path
for other outliers like himself to go on
and make [ __ ] you money and this is what
we want for these guys because what they
have at the end of the day once their
career is over
most of them don't have [ __ ] so that
what france is doing is going to change
the game forever and it is stressing the
ufc brass out
and that's what we want that means it's
working that means it's working i find
it interesting i i got a hold of francis
contract
in this day and age man i find it so
interesting you know because in his
champion uh
champion clause
you know
if you don't fight so that you have to
three fights or or a year a calendar
year so let's say francis doesn't
renegotiate with he's probably not but i
bet a lot of money he doesn't resign
with ufc um especially after the way
dana zack these past few days but
um
so he won't be able to work for a
calendar year that's in the contract he
won't be able to work for a calendar
year dude is it
is it 1964
what hold up be because i fought the
championship fight and now i can't work
for a year
in what world and in 2022
what world can a guy
where he served his contract and then he
can't work for a year
imagine any other job any other job any
other
even professional athlete job what other
job when you fulfill your contract
and you haven't resigned you can't work
for a year now there's there's no
compete clauses i get that so
you know if if uh let's say casey or
chin chin's my uh sound engineer expert
he has a no compete clause where he
couldn't go
let's say chin decided not to re-sign
tomorrow for another whatever six-year
contract whether he's gonna offer these
guys
he can't go to my direct competitor
for a certain amount of time there's a
non-compete
but he can still make money he could go
work you know like he just couldn't go
work for a chair selling
he couldn't work for ireland he couldn't
work who you know uh dan hardy
luke thomas he couldn't go do that but
he could do go
work with somebody else and make money i
can't prevent chin from making money
okay slavery's over right it doesn't
exist anymore
how these lawyers aren't eating this
[ __ ] up which i'm sure they are but
how you're not gonna allow a guy to work
for a year is insane man i i just so
so
put all that on the back burner that
that's what he's dealing with can't work
to the end of 2022. really january 1st
2023 he could figure things out with
tyson fury which tyson fury's foaming at
the dick to fight francis and ghana
which is great for all of us be so
entertaining right
here's the other caveat though
with his knee like i mentioned before
blown blown out mcl uh they don't know
if it's a terror strain of the acl all
the ligaments are messed up in there if
he has to have reconstructive surgery
he's out of here anyways
oh whoops that works for everybody
doesn't it he can't work anyways so that
kind of works to his benefit it's like
the stars are aligning for mr francis
ingano because
let's say the ufc is right you're done
you can fight you know fury in march he
can't do it oh he can fight fury in
july he can't do it so it kind of works
out for him it's really really worked
out for him so now he can focus on his
rehab uh even if he doesn't get the
reconstructive knee surgery let's say he
just uh has the mcl repaired you're
still out six months
um then you're looking at the build-up
of the fight the pre-fight promotions
you're still looking at 2023
it works perfect and then you can also
if six months just focus on boxing and
then the build up to it it works perfect
time wise sounds like it's gonna happen
kids but uh again if you're just a fight
fan in general you should be so proud of
francis ingano and how he represent
himself how he stuck to his bottom line
when all the odds were against him and
with all that he did it on one [ __ ]
leg and beat cyril gone how is that not
an inspirational story to you
you don't think hollywood's often movie
scripts about this
they are this adds to the story
adds to the story man it's fantastic but
yeah the [ __ ] you know the fight i'll
give it to you the fight wasn't the most
entertaining fight um especially had
preconceived notions going into it or
you had an expectation
but
he got it done and that's all that
matters at the end of the day he got it
done and wins a win um
so we know what's next for francis most
likely
for still cyril gone
i think his issue if you're
looking at this uh from the outside
looking in if you're his manager
i i think the ufc wanted cyril to
clearly beat francis to end up happening
but cyril's not the most exciting
heavyweight you know he looks like a
superhero but you know with the way he
fights he's very technical he's very
high iq
you know on the feet on the ground we
went for that you know ankle lock that
was very strange and completely uh lost
the round because of it
not the highest iq move there
but when it comes to stand up and
avoiding getting hit and his footwork
he's he might be the best we have to
offer at heavyweight
but i just don't know if you want that
type of fighting style your champ so
i would imagine for chirogun what they
do for him i think you're going to see
like a curtis blades next i do and that
would be a nightmare for cyril gone an
absolute nightmare i think you're gonna
see a little bit of a curtis blades
match up there which is a very very
[ __ ] tough stylistic matchup for
sarah gone i i you know i don't think
they're uh i think you're gonna get a
steep a john jones for the uh for the
intern belt because uh there's no way
they don't do an interim belt with
francis leaving or maybe it's just for
the belt because france is going to have
to vacate the belt depend on their
negotiations and you're getting a jon
jones uh stipe for the heavyweight world
title i bet you i would be willing to
bet a good amount of money that that's
what you get uh in 2022 your next major
major heavyweight fight is stipe
versus jon jones
and i i
and i know john tweeted out something
like maybe i should just stay re retired
after watching that fight i get that i
thought the same thing too when i saw
him like i don't know if you these guys
beat john
but remember caveat there
france had one leg
so
at johnny bones put if this is the apex
the heavyweight fight i'm excited about
it got some more records to break i
agree if you're drawn you're looking at
god eat these guys up because i love how
everyone gets so impressed with the new
guy
you should be impressed with your oh god
john it's not even that he's you know
he's undefeated but it was his movement
the way he moves like he's gonna be a
tough matchup for anybody including
yourself buddha
uh hello shout out just enjoy retirement
uh he won't
if anything this put more wind in john's
sales to go i can definitely beat these
guys i'm with you i thought the same
thing i was watching i thought oh
sargon's
this type of way with francis who's a
powerhouse with his takedown so you know
there's no knock on be down one leg but
if this is what he's like on the ground
he has some issues with john you know
some issues and he's not a knockout
artist but i don't think cyril gone gets
to jon jones i think john's jones is
gonna have focus on stipe which is a
tougher fight for him um
maybe and you know i don't think he's
have to worry about francis which i do
think would be the worst fight match up
for him stylistically he's gonna have to
worry about uh steep a and curtis blades
maybe cyril gone down the road but i
think for now his focus is gonna be on
stipe but
i would be willing to bet a lot of money
with francis leaving the ufc is going to
be willing to play ball with john and
john's gonna come to face the
heavyweight division uh but again john
verstipe now stipe wins jon just goes
away and you got john there you know you
got steve bay there but
it's fun it's a good time to be a fight
fan man a lot of drama
drama
um co-main event was fun
i thought
listen there's nobody nicer on the ufc
roster than brian moreno i thought he
lost a little bit of his edge he didn't
seem like the hungry young tijuana dog
that uh came in the last fight with a
chip on his shoulder he seemed
happy fat happy and um
he had his moments in the fight and he
definitely won some rounds 48-47 i'm
fine with that you could even gave it to
moreno a little bit i could have seen i
don't think anyway he got robbed there
figuritio's your jam
i don't think they do a match-up uh
rematch next as much as i'd love to see
i the only flyweights on c fight i do
bet i do believe that they will each
fight one more and then come back so you
can get a fourth one but not right away
there's argument brian moreno because
figuerito lost his
belt and they gave him a direct rematch
even though mourinho didn't want it he
said that on food truck
um so why won't you do that for brian
moreno
i don't think they will i think they
both take a fight and then fight each
other
um but i just thought moreno just wasn't
doing like i thought even though he only
lost 48 47 of the scorecards i just
think he had a little bit of an off
night i think maybe the success might
have got to matad and i'd be willing to
bet he beats the shita figurator the
next fight he's gonna learn he's gonna
beat him i thought figareto put his best
foot forward and got it done slightly
and moreno was off and that's why he
lost uh but i think if these boys fight
you know
ten times eight out of ten moreno wins
it was just you know an off night
chalk it up success finally made it is
you know once you win the belt the the
come down there so um i would i wouldn't
want to be the next guy who fights bran
moreno i just wouldn't he's gonna be
your champ he beats figarito eight times
out of ten but did not have it was not
his night
the the success maybe got to his head a
little bit maybe didn't do as much as he
usually does maybe he hit that extra
round maybe he hit the extra sprint or
maybe just his demeanor in there now
he's champ he's just now he's been to
the top of the mountain you know once
you get there
you're never going to see that view
again that view is always going to be
the same so
um i think he made a had that champion
come down almost as they called that
champion depression where you think that
once you get the belt all your worries
and concerns are answered and they are
not you feel exactly the same but you
have a belt around your waist and
everybody's gutting for you and he
didn't do something that you know and
maybe he did in camp but maybe the night
of the fight just it just didn't seem
like the normal
chomping at the bit brian moreno that we
know and love
and uh he'll learn from it i'm not
worried about him i'll learn from it
he'll be your champ for a very long time
but this was a learning lesson for him
so russ the card was good
pierre uh fiaho was a great fight
uh
nurga medoff uh cody stamen you know
cody stamen 47 seconds
uh morales looked fantastic
you know
tough night for full blown pay-per-view
it was tough i'm curious what the
numbers are
i don't think it did that great
wasn't a ton of buzz around it yeah even
though we're you know we're balls deep
in it i think there wasn't a ton of buzz
around it
i doubt it's out now but
let's see
this is from boardroom tv to 100 000
buys
that's terrible
if it's real yeah it'd be weird how they
would know how many right this i know
it's just too early but you know i would
say
on check the complete list through says
previous sales of uc are assumed to be
at 500 000.
that's it and wwe
oh no
oh that's just saying the payout yeah
yeah oh
not to be more than 500 000.
yeah i would say the pay-per-views does
around three to four hundred you know
where they they make their nut off 300
as long as they hit the 300 mark
anything below that
um they're not thrilled about
it it also doesn't help france's
negotiation power with tyson fury or the
ufc if it if it did low so you want to
do a little better but
you know sierra gone is not a household
name yet you know he's not an american
um his english is all right
do you think they made that card pretty
much just top just basically co-main
event main event and everything else is
kind of like whatever you think they
made it that way i like where your
head's at yeah i do chin
because if they were to stack that card
and that's great on pay-per-views it
really [ __ ] up france's uh negotiation
power
that's exactly what they did jin you're
100 correct wow that's very
disappointing
good call though thanks dude let's take
a little break from the chat
chatter because listen man there's a lot
of things going on right now in life
maybe it's politics
maybe it's uh the mandates in your city
maybe it's your your nfl team loss
whatever it is dude you need good sleep
and you have anxiety but listen it's
even worse if you have a bad mattress if
you're sleeping on a bad mattress or
maybe you grew up sleeping on a bad
mattress whatever it is man you don't
need that you don't need that my friends
at helix sleep they got you covered it's
what your thick friend sleeps on every
single night and i have them in all the
rooms in my house i can't get rid of my
in-laws my friends everybody wants to
sleep on my helic mattresses i say beat
it nerd get your own all you do is go to
helix sleep they get a quick quiz it
takes two minutes you complete they
match your body type with the perfect
mattress for your thick ass not all
mattresses are created equal not every
mattress is made for your big body this
mattress that helix sleep i promise you
will be the best mattress you're ever
gonna sleep on because made for you man
all right and listen don't take my word
for it helix sleep was awarded the
number one best overall mattress in 2019
and 2020 by gq'd and
wired magazine all right um i have in my
house i sleep on them i'm telling you
i've been using this several years and i
freaking love it i don't have any back
pains none of that stuff it's the best
mattress i've ever slept on just go to
helixsleep.com
[Music]
take their two-minute sleep quiz they
will match you with a customized
mattress just for you that will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty you get to try it out
100 nights risk-free if you don't love
it cool they'll pick it up for you uh
but it doesn't matter because you're
gonna love it guarantee it helix is
offering you guys up to 200 off all
mattress orders and free pillows for the
listeners and viewers of the shop show
go to helixsleep.com
that's helixsleep.com
sleep.com
shob for up to 200 off
man there are only four teams left in
the nfl playoffs if you're not watching
the playoffs you're missing the best
football i've ever seen the chiefs and
bills you kidding me the rams and tampa
bay was insane and listen there's four
teams left
and you need to bet on them you got to
do with draftkings the official sports
betting partner of the nfl counting down
to super wall 56 right here in los
angeles counting down new customers can
get 56 to 1 odds on any team bet just 5
and get 280 in free bets if your team
wins take the rams over the niners i
think we're gonna get over this hump and
i really do uh not a new customer cool
you can experience conference
championship with the same game parlays
that's right combine multiple bets from
the same game for a bigger payout the
more legs you add the more money you can
win that's what i usually like to do is
parlays the best bang for your buck it's
kind of tricky but if you do hit you're
making bank draftkings a safe secure
reliable best of all you can deposit and
withdraw your cash whenever you want man
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now use the promo code shobb sch
aub and get 56 to 1 odds on any nfl team
bet just five dollars and win 280 in
free bets if your team wins that's promo
code shob sch aub for just
56 to 1 odds at draftking sportsbook
official sportsman partner the nfl must
be 21 or older new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only
minimum five dollar deposit one dollar
wager required
what else you got dude all right so this
prelim fighter the early prelim her name
is vanessa demofulos i think she's the
one that jumped in yeah yep the one that
jumped in rogan's arms
um there she is right there so she did a
crazy comeback she was getting destroyed
and then finally landed an arm bar which
i don't think we could play the video
but so she used to be a stripper so she
quit stripping like a few weeks
beforehand to focus 100 on mma and the
interesting thing about the
interesting thing about that is her
parents
they met in the same industry her dad
was a dj and her mom's just uh
this is fantastic exotic entertainer
that's what they said and they kind of
like it's a family thing yeah dancer mom
was a dancer be cool man
and she's also let me just play school
she might be my favorite fighter now
carry on cool
[Applause]
i don't think it's a secret i was an
exotic entertainer for 13 years and um i
didn't actually say this on the mic
i walked away from being a stripper to
continue this camp um i quit dancing
about like six to eight weeks ago just
so i could focus full-time on mma take
this extremely seriously this is
fantastic
so um yeah but that's that's where that
background comes from that's where those
splits come from and a lot of my jiu
jitsu actually comes from my expertise
as a pole dancer okay well
[Music]
she's great i don't have enough fingers
and toes to tell you how awesome i feel
times 100. her energy is fantastic
clearly good on the mic after being a
stripper talking to guys all [ __ ]
night
and she's gonna have gift of the gab for
the mo unless dude and you know if
you've ever been a straight club the
baddest girl is usually the worst at
talking because they don't have to do
any talking but she's you know she's not
bad looking she's not halle berry like
if if you're kind of like that middle
tier stripper your [ __ ] gift of the
gap better be good you gotta talk these
you know these these joes into spending
some dollars so she's gonna be a
marketing powerhouse dude she's also an
author
stripper bible yep well she's fantastic
yeah she's like a
multi-talented girl
keep going down
she jumped in rogan's arms yeah which
was cool that's so cool and she got the
50 000 bonus i think she did let's see
she did
yeah she did wow perform fantastic great
content that's so cool man how crazy is
that family business they're all in the
same thing yeah yeah listen that's
fantastic what a great story what a
unique story too definitely and her
energy is contagious
that's great man
she keeps winning you got something big
time oh yeah
okay let's go to this is interesting as
well france sagano will take half of his
purse so 300 grand pretty much in
bitcoin i guess it's the first time they
did it
uh it says then give it to his fans
i don't think fans did it
i believe bitcoin can empower people
here so i'm excited to partner with cash
up take half my eoc 70 bitcoin also it's
more accessible to his fans i want to
make bitcoin more successful than my
fans so i'm giving out 300k in bitcoin
follow cash app oh okay so i would
imagine cash out was a k he signed a
deal with them and they said and we'll
give you an extra 300k to give out to
your fans there you go that's what
happened
now was it it was i think it was crypto
just ate [ __ ] was it crypto let me see
was it crypto i know netflix took a like
a huge dive um
[Music]
no it's a bitcoin
yeah bitcoin took a huge huge uh dip
huge dip
like basically like because uh obj uh
odell beckham jr wanted uh to be paid
his salary in uh bitcoin
but you're assuming what it was being
traded at when you wanted it and now
it's worth like half and i think it's
going even lower
but it's gonna bounce back so if you
don't have money and you let's let's say
i i
i have no idea how
obj spends his money i have no idea if
he's great with money or not but um
let's say you weren't you're living
paycheck to paycheck and you were
banking on
i don't know let's say
10 million dollars and then it cuts it's
down 40 percent yeah so 40 of your
salary now so if you need to take that
money out now you're kind of [ __ ] yeah
but if you look at like an investment
it's gonna bounce back you know it's
like a stock it's gonna bounce it's
gonna be bounce back you'll be fine have
you thought or are you in the process of
like investing in yeah i'm investing
okay yeah but it's a long it's a long
play like i don't look at any of this i
know it's down all that stuff and
bitcoin and all that it's down that's
whatever it but it's a long play
my friend just bought a boat and he's a
young kid and doesn't have a job yet so
i'm like holy crap i'm super interested
in kryptonite crypto yeah yeah i don't
know enough about it there's people
making tons of money off crypto tons of
money yeah it's really cool
but uh yeah
you wouldn't want to be living paycheck
to paycheck and banking on crypto and
bitcoin paying your money right now no
paying your salary
investment dope
if you needed to [ __ ] buy the kids
meals on friday not good
all right so this is uh nate diaz nate
diaz and dustin poury have been going
back and forth for a while they both
said they want the fight remember
they're scheduled to fight a long time
ago yeah yeah and they wanted to go to
165 too so there's nate diaz talking
about nathan diaz says ufc stopped
playing with me considering he said
that's him that's wit so stop playing
with me consider this my signature to
fight this [ __ ] i've been trying to
fight for a minute quit slowing down the
real fight game it's time agree nathan
and then uh poor said the real fight
game i'm gonna fight your ass
yeah
and they post a poster of it okay
and so
this is dana white's it says of course
we're interested this what we do we make
fights every weekend what happens is
guys just want to jump out of nowhere
and say all right i want to do this i
want to do that
we have fights booked up until i want to
say may 2nd right now everything is in
place everything is done obviously nate
diaz will get fights i say this all the
time it says for 20 years we're
contracted to give guys fights three
times a year they've got to get fights
nate will get a fight yeah but we want
what does important yeah
i bet it happens
but yeah you know guys get frustrated
when it's not at on their timeline
but to dana's defense he's like yeah
yeah man we can't just
all right you guys want to fight next
month like the the card's booked so if
we put you guys on there in your main
event what do you do with that we gotta
shuffle [ __ ] around let's just do this
the proper way and you guys will fight
in say june
and we'll make that happen because we
don't have june booked yet but guys get
so frustrated when does it happen like
this
and you also mentioned before that you
know since it's his last fight the ufc
might want to have him fight conor yeah
all right so they're just trying to
figure it out trying to figure where
conor's at they're waiting what they're
doing is buying time with this yeah
all right
uh so
could be you know his eagle fc that is
just his promotion they started he
offered jake to fight there but then
jake had one little caveat to it
so this isn't any typed in [ __ ]
russian yeah
at jake paul i don't know why the doors
of eagle fight club always open for you
and your team
and then jake paul says deal only if i
fight you first
in mma
well maybe it's like just in the eagle
fc but then they'll do boxing something
like that
well he better pray to the [ __ ]
youtube gods that he didn't fight khabib
and mma because he wanted a box he's
just doing it to [ __ ] around for sure
but i mean they're both talking to each
other which is cool i bet they figure
something out that'll be huge hilarious
and this is dana white actually saying
never say never if jake paul were to
find the oc they was on that full send
podcast i believe
so i'll just play this for you real
your quick
well it's not that he doesn't have my
respect um you know i don't even know
the kid at the end of the day i i don't
even know the kid and you know what to
be honest with you i'll tell you right
here right now this is the last time you
hear me talking about him i'm i'm done i
put out the challenge he said you know
you do coke
you know i said i think you're not mad
at dana's kids
will do it he never responded to it so
fire away kid do your thing i'm you know
i'm sitting here i'm arguing with this
kid that doesn't fight for me and is
never going to fight for me so what's
what's the point even he and i going
back and forth with each other what if
he was to come into the ufc what if he
would what if he came into mma would you
let him
would i let him well he can do whatever
he wants to do like what if he's like i
want to fight in the ufc
i don't know
i don't think that would ever happen but
listen i never say never anymore you
know
that'd be pretty i didn't think
and conor would end up or i would do end
up doing any of my guys versus floyd
because that just makes absolutely no
sense but
it happened so
i'm with him yeah i never say no you
know that's pretty cool yeah that's
pretty cool he's even saying that
how can he never say never yet see him
punk fight
right now jake paul is more than
qualified thank you huge it would be
freezing he's more qualified for sure
yeah
but that would be insane
that'd be nuts
and
the rock they made this announcement i
think on espn
that he his shoe
project rock is going to be the like the
actual outfitter for the fighters up
until they get into the cage so they'll
probably yeah
doesn't make shoes remember reebok did
they need a shoe deal
god you know what's so weird remember i
was talking about conflict of interest
god who represents the
wme
god who owns coc we have me
who did the shoe deal wme
dwayne ufc they own them both okay
who else you gonna go with
i scratch my back you scratch yours
do you have any opinions i mean both of
you guys i've seen the under armour
shoes just the rock ones
i don't know if i'm just like out of it
but they just look really not good to me
i like well i'm not wearing i heard
they're great i'm not wearing them with
jeans but as far as functional yeah rock
workout shoes are dope are they
engineered really really well they're
really good but they just the yeah they
look like i see i see what you're saying
they look dope though they function dope
right they function dope i don't mind
the look of the workout ones the high
top workout ones i don't like the ones
that get in the ufc fighters but the mid
like high tops that they make for
working out are sick i try to get them
they sold out you know you know way more
about shoes than me but yeah i'm not
gonna wear them with jeans look like a
[ __ ] dork
like i'm at a [ __ ] gnc convention or
some [ __ ] on the streets you know
but in the in the gym they're dope he is
so shredded right here yeah so i'll play
this little this is them on espn and
then this last part i thought was very
interesting i can't wait okay nothing
better than actors talking ufc
i mean so this you'll see what i'm
saying
give me one sec
is does he have to hold on before you is
it him breaking down francis cyril no no
this is him talking about what his
biggest patch or the the biggest thing
he wants to do for the xfl like who he
cares about most the thing that he cares
about the most and dana white is on this
call as well it's gonna be so awkward so
he's gonna see them getting paid
carry on uh exciting play innovative
ruling innovative game play uh exciting
for the fans but most importantly as
someone this is the exact same way i
feel about the ufc fighters but most
importantly with the xfl my number one
goal as owner as an owner is to take
care of the players and to create an
opportunity for the players to live out
their dreams to take care of their
families pay their bills play with pride
pay play with passion and and play uh
proudly in the xfl that's the goal
dana's like this and obviously dana is
already locked in for season two right
dana
yeah so i hope so
it's such an awkward moment too
but also when it comes to football it's
like yeah have you ever heard like they
need to pay these guys more i know like
patrick mahomes [ __ ] making whatever
the biggest contract of all time i'll
tell you one thing i people always say
these nfl players are paid way too
less they need to pay them more says no
one ever you know what i'm saying
i'm sure they get paid less but it's
still oh yeah they're not talking okay
they're just still staying
you know what i'm saying yeah dave was
just sitting there like god damn it rock
what what if what if rock was one that
made the change he's like dana are you
with me man i'll tell you what i'm gonna
do
i'm gonna give these guys 50 of their
total
income will you do the same dan's all
we'll talk man
excited for fast and furious 17 or what
the [ __ ] you're trying to do
yeah that was awkward yeah i love when
they go jamie's face he's all i know
he's
almost pissed off
you heard this already but amanda nunes
left att to start our own team yeah
um
in her own gym
linus has called home for the past seven
years now 33 year old intent to start
her own place alongside her partner
current ufc strawweight fighter nina
nunes for now the new gym does not have
a name or location yet
um interesting so still in the same area
stay safe same time the bigger question
for
uh
amanda nunes that i'd be curious about
although you're starting your own gym
which i'm sure att is fine with are you
working with the same team
that's what's important
you'll be training out of your [ __ ]
garage which you're same team i'm on
board if you're going all new coaches
everything something's going on
and we should be alarmed
and some people are thinking that it's
because you know uh kayla harrison
you know she's since she's in the same
gym they might do whatever but then
apparently kayla harrison is
like uh most likely going to stay with
the pfl like that's the top decision
right now that's so shame it wouldn't be
in the ufc anyways if that's true
and
this is what chelsea said about uh
jorge mosby
in all fairness i've really got to show
respect about this jail certainly i'm
talking about yeah not me uh in all
fairness i've really got to show respect
to moswell because this is a career
ending fight
it's that big of a deal there will be
that much attention that much much focus
and that much hatred going on into this
battle with george who's the second
biggest strong combat right now he's
coming off two defeats if he goes out
there and he gets taken down he gets
mauled for 25 minutes he's going to take
a lot of luster off the shine that's
that is the second biggest draw the the
bmf horizon hospital
it's a big deal and where he signed up
anyway goddamn respect that
man i don't know if it's career ending
for him
you know if he gets people off george
and if jorge uh oh what he said
responded back i personally like chael a
little bothered by that comment but it's
kind of like it just sets up the [ __ ]
mountain to be a lot higher when i climb
it chill's like i can't believe you
climbed that mountain i'm gonna be like
i told you [ __ ]
i get it man two white boys
that's exactly where i was gonna go with
this well come on jory you know why he's
riding with his boy colby i get it man
two white boys from oregon they both
have that sleazeball style like cutting
edge at the time i thought shell did it
in a more classy way i agree but he
still said things that didn't need to be
said like bringing up anders silva's
wife so this type of guy's got to stick
together but i like him though because
chael's the type of guy that will go
back and apologize so when i [ __ ]
murder colby he has to be like holy [ __ ]
this guy deserves a title fight blah
blah blah he's right
and then he starts here again chao had
to be [ __ ] talking because he didn't
have any exciting style for a long time
he was just wrestling guys to death so
he had to do that extra talk and get
himself over like that that influenced
guys like kobe that's all he does 100 i
don't take whatever chill or colby says
chosen i enjoy it it's entertainment
none of it would be personal jail came
out i talked to you know chill had the
whole
[ __ ] with the police guy
i reached out to me and trailer friends
actual friends cheo could go on and show
them back i hate job and this this get
the views from it none of that bothers
me anything he says about me i don't see
none of it bothers me fans are like oh
you hear what chael said yeah it's for
the for he's doing for the gram let's do
them for the gram
that's funny
all right
um
now it's official glover took sierra and
europe
here he got the five yeah dfc 274
i mean you know uh global tech jarrah
you know such a great story being at his
age and coming back and being the light
heavyweight champ and we're all rooting
for him and you know i thought he was
going to get it done against yon dolga
but um
unless he can get yuri down man it's
gonna be a tough night for him not the
best matchup for him yawn great matchup
for glover yary nightmare unless he can
get those stake downs wear them out in
in impose his you know his grappling
game on him and really wear him out but
man early on it's gonna be he's gonna
get lit up he get lit up
and then he's gonna eat some big shots
and if he can get a hold of him it's glo
once hits the mat glover all day but on
the feet
tough
night for glover
yuri's a monster yeah all the experience
of glover and yours that crazy wild dude
yeah you can't train for them yeah
another cool fight alexander volkov and
tom aspana who's been killing it tom
asman now this is the fast track for tom
and he he said listen i don't want to
fight for the title i'm like i want to
work my way up well
uh bubba for tom you knock out volkov
it's off to the races pal
volkov is a [ __ ] monster
you knock him out on march 19th the day
after my birthday you knock him out and
then we're looking at you know top four
off to the races for tom
yup and that's where remember you posted
about it they opened up london yeah
how great is that man
[ __ ] yeah london ireland fully open no
mandates
yes
tour
yes dude it was enormous how many people
came out so i know we haven't been there
in what six years yeah maybe five five
five isha dude go back now hell yeah
dude oh my gosh you gotta be done for
that
all right uh dan hooker his official
first fight at 145 will be
[ __ ] fight for his first fight at 45
you give him marvel to allen allen's a
[ __ ] beast yeah
so it's dan hooker though i love dan
hooker
yep so there you go that's on that
london card yeah and is it it's a fight
night i don't i'm guessing it's not
gonna be fight night right
you see london's a fight it's a fight
night so you're gonna have dan hooker
arnold allen which is [ __ ] fire
volkov [ __ ] is your main event
also five rounds for our boy aspie there
yeah and jumping way to the top real
quick
rooting for tom man
uh your boy you know magni for the
longest time we thought he might be
matched up with hamza but now he's
matched up with max griffin what the
[ __ ] are they gonna do with uh harms out
then so
go into that let's see here
hamza called out gilbert burns
who's what like number two or three
right now
and gilbert burns did reply as well
[Music]
well first i'll show you what hamza said
to gilbert
this hamza up top there yep everybody
talking about me but nobody wants to
fight me because we kill everybody fair
for me it doesn't matter gilbert burns
talked about brazil i'm more brazilian
than him because my coach is brazilian
on my blue belt under alan
i know many times my coach smashed burns
too on the mats
jesus
and then he hums out says we're going to
choke him out uh a finfu blue belt
against a black belt i like this guy
actually he's funny nice guy gilbert's
the nicest guy i want to fight with him
but in war brother i can't be nice with
somebody i want to eat everybody take my
money take my belt i'm so hungry when i
talk about fighters i'm hungry
i do not see gilbert burns beating him
nowadays man and just again it's off to
the races you're number 11 now you beat
number two
there's only one way to go up it's the
winner of [ __ ] uh
uh
kobe comington and
[ __ ] jorge you're gonna get the
winner of that
then what but i think he's right out of
anybody he's ready for it that we get we
can't feed him any anybody [ __ ] ten
through five he he's just demolishing he
literally destroys yeah we gotta this
makes sense he's proved it already he
deserves to be on stop
damn i think gilbert's all about make it
happen dude i'm all in five rounds in
brazil i think they should do it
i don't like that fight for gilbert at
all in any facet
harms that's a [ __ ] maniac i know
i believe in him now
yeah me too
uh also hamza joined tiger muta along
with pedrion and rafael physique jesus
christ he's in thailand he's saying
you're trying to yeah stand up jesus
christ
off to the races
yeah
uh we talked about roy nelson we didn't
know he was up to lately but i guess
he's talking to scott coker and bellator
and possibly even that triad combat
place that'd be cool for roy yeah
and he wants to fight fedor that's
that's reason wants to do bellator i
would love that for roy roy versus fedor
i'm all about
yeah i thought you'd get roy on food
truck yeah it's been a while see it'd be
cool to see what he's up to right now
wouldn't it be fun to have him on food
truck and then have him on classic fight
companion because there's gonna watch me
versus oh dude that'd be sad
everything going through your mind his
mind i'll tell him yeah you're dope dude
yeah that's exactly i'm gonna reach out
though
there you go
uh we talked about this already
oh so remember brennan ward from
bellators a while back he was there he
was like uh he was doing pretty well
what about i'll show you this picture
here just in case
it buddied up bought it up good looking
dude yep um
yeah that's the guy
he was doing well and then he just kind
of disappeared he got caught up in drugs
i think since 2017 he got really bad all
of his friends
the people around him died so finally
we're down fentanyl meth
it's always like the opiate stuff he was
into the opiates yeah okay he got
hardcore into it
there's like a huge story on him but uh
now he's returning to uh bellator
him i'm assuming he's clean yeah yeah
that's the toughest fight you're gonna
fight my man that's great
so yeah that's quick rooting for him
this one's crazy do you remember macau
falco i don't know i'll show you this
guy he was in the ufc for a while he's
also a bellator
okay uh so the crazy thing about this
guy
there was he would test that guy yeah
for sure
um so he
he was involved in some sort of street
fight a long time ago this was like
maybe eight years ago or something that
says eight years ago
so he got i'll just show you this video
first this is simple yeah video him yeah
this is like yeah and this is the reason
why he was kicked out of the ufc or
bellator okay
[Music]
right there
he's wearing his own shirt that's fine
what's he saying to those ladies he was
trying to flirt and then oh he hit him
yeah he swiped at her and then
people from the outside side
oh [ __ ] yeah he's drunk right oh he's
hammered because he's not fighting at
all so his homeboy is also a fighter
so he goes outside and boom his homeboy
gets hit in the head with the pipe
he got hit in the head with a pipe too
yeah well he got drunk he got dropped
that's him there i think so holy [ __ ]
oh oh i think that's his homeboy that
guy's
oh my god yeah he got jacked oh they're
trying to kill him
so he got knocked out they both got
knocked out and then they keep kicking
him in the head yeah but he wasn't as
damaged as others the other guy got
really jacked up but so he had like this
downward spiral where he's getting
street fights yeah getting drunk and
then he's finally
stabbed
[Music]
he [ __ ] died
holy [ __ ] man
that's terrible yeah
god he was 26 and three
wow he was actually he beat uh gerald
harris
that's terrible yeah stabbed i mean
incidents they occurred around 3am jesus
christ
that's terrible yep
what's this gin so terence crawford is
suing bob aaron
for it says here nearly 10 million
dollars and he's alleging
revolting racist but racial bias he's
saying that
i'll actually show you this for her so
the lawsuit alleges aaron engaged in
revolting racial bias that prevented
crawford from booking big fights
according to the new york post and then
this is what he says here this is
crawford for years
professional boxers and others in sports
would have called out top ranks owner
bob aaron for his
disparate the spirit treatment of black
boxing one of those very same black
boxers that top rank is
contractually obligated to promote
and then hold on this is bob aaron
says it's absurd my whole career i may
have made mistakes but one thing i
cannot be accused of being racist i've
promoted scores of top black boxers
we've promoted a number of pay-per-view
fights for terrence all of which have
lost money a lot of money than to claim
we purposely and deliberately lost money
because we're racist it's nonsense it's
part of what is wrong with our culture
agree i'm flabbergasted if we believe i
didn't if he believes i didn't do a good
job crawford can plead the
that in his suit but don't call a man
racist when uh it's really because your
own failures
yeah i
i don't know the uh
the numbers the tax brass of all this
but you know i think for crawford you
know we've had him on food truck
skill wise yeah man one of the top guys
out there but as far as mark-ability
generating numbers yeah it's tough so
for bob arum
you can't force anything so you can you
know he can win the fights and all that
stuff
um
i think
i don't know if i would
i don't know if i would sh you know sue
for being racist i would sue
for not give him the fights that we want
to see
that's boxing it's not a racist thing
you know
the issue with boxing is we don't get
the fights you want to see that's why
boxing's dying unless you're a
heavyweight boxer so
um or unless you're a youtuber boxing's
dying yeah showtime edit that out they
can't now
um
so i i think you know i i think
you know i think crawford has looks in
the look in the mirror a little bit here
you know and i i don't it's more of a
marketing play for bob aaron here
it's not i don't think it's cause he's
racist towards black fighters
uh floyd mayweather uh who also worked
with aaron made similar comments after
ending his relationship with bob arum
mayweather claimed aaron was biased
against black fighters until night in
2009 interview with fight hype
mayweather also said he earned less when
working with airmen that mayweather's
profits increases significantly uh once
he left the same year airing claim
mayweather was not an entertaining
fighter in played mayo they were soft
and that he shoots up cars away from the
ring
shoots the cars away from the ring yeah
i don't know what that is i i i can be
racist and be a [ __ ] involve the
sports is insane he's he seems like a
just a weird
money-hungry guy old guy yeah sleazy
promoter
no promoter makes you feel good
uh i don't know if we'll actually cover
this but i'll just show you this anyways
i thought this was weird because okay so
you see
they do these like pre-shows and they do
like fun activities like eating contests
and everything else well they do it on
their youtube uh yeah
espn youtube channel okay or ufc all
right so this one was a skateboarding
competition and is that laura's thank
you that's laura senko timepiece super
done yeah
and then also daniel cormier uh this
host as well and and dean thomas okay so
i love all three of them involved i'm
just tripping out because they're all
athletes right
but i guess skateboarding is completely
different but so they're going to do
this little skateboard race
skateboarding's [ __ ] tough but i mean
just this
it's just tough to balance
well you should uh dean's eye dean smart
don't be in balance
[Laughter]
cdc don't balance just keep pushing it
oh [ __ ]
he fell athletically though
holy [ __ ] this thing's a [ __ ] show
i'll tell you right now it's
entertaining though i'm with it
oh my god
is senko good at it
i'd say they're almost all equal uh i'd
say senko's probably the best you'll see
here
uh you're not allowed to touch it or
something i don't know
america i'm into it i don't know is that
who's the white guy he's that the host
of the show i don't know who was his
name but he's a host of the show
i mean yeah the weigh-in show yeah it's
just i i was kind of into it i know it's
cool no i'm saying it's cool i just
thought that they'd be able to at least
write like at least write it a little
bit did you see dc uh he was a goalie i
think against the anaheim ducks
see that i think he posted it or ufc
posted he was a good and i mean they
[ __ ] went easy on him but they
definitely that'd be a scary [ __ ] gig
he wasn't terrible we can tell like
those guys are so athletic man here we
are
[Music]
and they're being cool to him too yeah
that's like like like imagine a full
[ __ ] hockey
[Applause]
[Music]
oh they're trying to fight
okay
sam
your fighting skills is
so it's great i really love it but let
me show you one thing when you get in
here right we take the underhook yeah
it's called dirty box you are yeah under
hook and hockey so when you take this
here under hook there yeah and you start
to punch don't go ahead
hit him right up on the elbow here and
then
the right hand over the top try that try
to help with it so here
body shot first
and then over the top
that's the one don't waste your time
it's pretty dope huh
love dc just can't
can't skate yeah this game
that it dude yeah so we do have a couple
of fights nothing big
um let's go
[Music]
here so eagle fc 44 supposed to take
place january 28th is in florida yeah at
6 00 p.m eastern and the headlining one
is tyrone spong versus sergey kiritonov
and then your boy rashad evans
against that gabriel checko and then ray
borg is actually going to be on this
card jim that's cool yeah cody gibson
damn i'm so interesting to see how the
production this thing is
i mean it's gonna be dope that's on
friday or saturday said i believe that's
saturday where can you watch it is it on
five pass
um
they're supposed to be on five pass
interesting
let's see
let me actually look it up real quick
eaglefc.com then that's where you watch
it eaglefc.com
it's kind of cool though yeah i mean i
recognize the names i mean why wouldn't
flight pass just
i mean they were supposed to they were
in talks about doing that too so i'm not
sure what's happening there maybe it is
available on five pieces as well i'll
watch that for sure
spun kiritonov is great
let's do it and then there's a real
quick bkfc one i think this is on friday
no 20th so that i think let me look at
the 20th real quick
all right so eagle fc is the 28th which
is friday and then bkfc is the 29th
which is saturday and then this one the
only name i recognize right here was
alan belcher but the new jacked crazy
city belcher yeah it's fantastic yep
but that's about it all right slow
weekend yeah maybe they just don't want
to compete with nfl playoffs i don't
know
because playoffs are popping yesterday's
games were so [ __ ] good the rams baby
hopefully they get over the [ __ ]
niners next week
and i'm room for cinci over kc cincy uh
ram super i'll be fantastic all right
kids that's it i hope you enjoyed it we
have a uh
classic cowbest fight companion dropping
on wednesday
this week if you haven't checked out the
food truck diet with sugar sean o'malley
that's available right now on thick boy
youtube audio is also available
um the current calabash fight campaign
for ufc 270 is available on think boy
youtube and audio all audio platforms
and if you want all that ad free go to
fakeboy.supercast.com subscribe right
now you also get find the kid ad free as
well on there in the second tier and uh
hollywood improv i will see you this
wednesday there are not many tickets
left it will be shaub and friends i have
some
monster friends coming to slang them
jokes this wednesday at the hollywood
improv january 26th atlanta just got
announced so atlanta these tickets will
go fast it's not a giant room atlanta
georgia february 3rd through the 5th
sacramento is february 24th through 26th
this saturday is the thick mudder at 10
a.m in lake elsinore it's orange county
your boy's gonna be there
i would say right now my leg is a four
out of ten but i'm doing everything uh
in
breach to get this leg so i can at least
run that race that uh 15k race on
saturday i'm gonna run it i don't know
how fast i don't know if i'll make it
through all of it but i will be there
and i will run it 10 a.m can sign up
there are 10 spots left to run the thick
mudder this saturday you can go to tough
uh it's all over by instagram you'll see
it there as well but that's this
saturday at 10 am you can do it come do
it with me i'm doing it with one [ __ ]
leg listen if francis beats your gun on
one knee i can run the tough mudder on
one hamstring all right um
yeah and we'll have the special uh thick
mud or merch you see me rock it now says
thick mudder on the back it's a collab
we did with built those will be on sale
only in person at the tough mudder stern
at 9 00 a.m in lake elsinore
once you get there you will have
somebody set the shop up the thick boy
tough mudder
shop up so
we'll see you saturday 10 a.m hopefully
your boy makes it through it love you
guys thanks for listening thanks for
watching like subscribe our youtube
channel and uh everything we're doing
man appreciate guys i think we just
passed 115 000 subscribers on youtube so
that bad boy's uh this was the vision
man so we're rolling make sure you like
subscribe uh whatever you got to do man
but uh georgia europe february 3rd
through the 5th atlanta atl
put down them hot wings and uh whatever
else you got going on bring your thick
asses out to atlanta february 3rd
through the 5th love you guys thanks for
listening i'm out